Então, o que eu quero fazer na aula
de hoje é mudar um pouco
o panorama sobre o que falamos
na 1ª unidade do curso.
Como vocês sabes, a 1ª unidade
do curso foi enfocada numa
série de textos que se preocupavam
com a prosperidade humana.
E embora o nosso texto de
abertura, o desafio de Glauco
em A República de Platão, se
preocupe com a moralidade
e como a moral contribui para a
prosperidade humana, nós não
temos dado, até agora, muita
atenção para o que os filósofos
têm a dizer sobre a
natureza da moralidade.
E o objetivo desta unidade é, de uma
forma extremamente rápida,
apresentar hoje e na próxima
terça, 2 das teorias morais
mais importantes na tradição
ocidental e, em seguida, nas sessões
restantes antes da pausa de
março, comentar
sobre algumas pesquisas
empíricas sobre essas questões.
E eu sei que esta turma possui uma
grande diversidade de experiências.
Alguns de vocês estão no seu
1º curso de Filosofia.
Outros estão tendo um curso
completo sobre ética.
Por isso, eu tentei preparar
a aula de tal forma
que ela contemple a todos, mas de
tal modo que, eu espero,
não aborreça àqueles que
já viram isso antes.
Em especial, para compensar o fato
de que há pouca psicologia
empírica nesta aula, temos 6
slides de enquetes.
Eles vão surgir na metade da
aula, justamente no momento
em que vocês começarem a cochilar
porque dormiram apenas 2
horas na noite anterior.
Mesmo se vocês não tiverem
prestado atenção à 1ª parte,
terão de votar.
Tudo bem, então o que a filosofia
moral se propõe a fazer?
O que é isso de fornecer uma
explicação filosófica da moralidade?
A filosofia moral é o esforço
sistemático para compreender os
conceitos morais e justificar os
princípios morais e teorias.
Ou seja: a filosofia moral, mesmo
que acabe dando uma resposta
não-sistemática de como a moralidade
funciona e o que a moralidade
faz, faz isso dentro do esforço
de pensar sistematicamente
sobre a natureza da moralidade.
O que eu quero dizer com moralidade?
Quero dizer que as teorias morais
objetivam proporcionar modelos
de termos como "certo" e "errado",
"admissível" e "inadmissível ",
"deve" e "não deve", "proibido",
"bom", "ruim" e análogos...
e fornecer um modelo de comportamentos
a que esses termos se aplicam.
Ela é, fundamentalmente – para
mencionar uma distinção terminológica
que fizemos antes –, uma
iniciativa normativa
em vez de uma descritiva.
A teoria moral filosófica
não pretende dizer
como as pessoas agem.
Ela se destina a dizer como
as pessoas devem agir
se desejam estar em
conformidade com as
restrições
que a moralidade deposita nelas.
Em particular, a filosofia moral
se preocupa em fornecer
uma resposta baseada em princípios
para 3 tipos de perguntas.
O 1º tipo já foi encontrado no
contexto do desafio de Glauco.
É a questão da motivação moral.
"Por que queremos agir
de acordo com o que a
moralidade exige de nós?"
E, daqui a 1 minuto, eu vou dar a
vocês uma noção da variedade
de respostas que foram
fornecidas para essa pergunta.
Assim, a 1ª questão que a
filosofia moral coloca é
por que nós ainda queremos ser morais.
Em seguida, ela faz o
questionamento particular:
"O que devemos fazer à medida que
buscamos agir moralmente?"
E sobre isso nós tivemos muito
pouco a dizer até agora.
Sabemos que, segundo
Aristóteles, para ser corajoso
você tem de atuar como um corajoso.
Mas Aristóteles apresentou a
coragem como uma virtude
sem qualquer explicação sobre o
que faz a coragem estar
na categoria de virtudes e a
covardia na categoria de vícios,
com nada mais que uma análise
muito geral do significado.
E nós ainda não analisamos todas
as alegações específicas
sobre as ações particulares serem
moralmente aceitáveis ou não.
Portanto, o 2º tipo de coisa que
uma teoria moral tenta fazer
– e, mais uma vez, vou dar alguns
exemplos daqui a pouco –
é dar respostas
específicas para a
pergunta:
"Esta ação está moralmente OK?".
Além disso, o que uma teoria
moral visa fazer é dizer
por que deu as respostas
feitas na questão 2.
"Em virtude de que
características comuns
as ações enquadradas na
categoria de moral
se distinguem das ações
enquadradas na categoria de imoral?"
Então, quais seriam as respostas
para essas 3 perguntas?
Vamos começar,
uma vez que já encontramos isso na
questão da motivação moral.
Uma classe de respostas
possíveis para o por quê
seria moral agir de acordo com as
restrições da moralidade
é um modelo do interesse próprio.
Alguém pode apresentar um
modelo que diz:
quando você se comporta
moralmente, as coisas funcionam
bem.
Como Sócrates argumenta na
resposta a Glauco,
quando você se comporta de acordo com
as restrições da moralidade,
há harmonia na sua alma.
E isso proporciona a você a possibilidade
de um certo tipo de prosperidade.
Ou você pode ter o que está
implícito no argumento inicial
de Glauco, uma visão de
que a moralidade
fornece um certo tipo de
estabilidade na sociedade.
Cada um de nós se comportando
de maneira pró-social
aumenta a probabilidade dos
outros, ao nosso redor,
se comportarem de maneira pró-social.
E assim chegamos a uma espécie
de estado de equilíbrio
em que as coisas funcionam bem,
se todo mundo se comporta
pró-socialmente.
E vamos falar sobre isso novamente
no início da seção de
filosofia política.
Portanto, a teoria do interesse próprio
apela para um certo tipo de
coordenação, seja uma coordenação
entre as partes da alma ou entre os
indivíduos de uma sociedade.
Um 2º tipo de teoria do
interesse próprio
é o que podemos chamar de
"obter as coisas boas".
Ela está no cerne de algumas
tradições religiosas.
Aqui está o que você recebe se agir
de acordo com as restrições
da moralidade: você obtém a vida
eterna num lugar muito agradável.
Aqui está o que você
recebe se não agir
de acordo com as
restrições da moralidade:
você obtém a eternidade num
lugar muito desagradável.
Portanto, a noção de que há
alguma recompensa além da Terra
por se comportar de maneiras morais
é um exemplo de uma justificação de
interesse próprio da moralidade.
Ou alguém pode dar o tipo
de justificativa
que Adimanto dá no desafio de Glauco.
Adimanto salienta que uma das
coisas que a moralidade
fornece é uma reputação melhor.
Como resultado de se comportar
de acordo com os padrões de moralidade,
você é percebido como tendo se
comportado dessa forma
e essa reputação aporta
algum valor para você.
Ou pode ser, como Aristóteles
pondera no final do Livro X,
que a sociedade está
estruturada de alguma forma
que motiva as pessoas a agirem de
acordo com as restrições
da moralidade, afinal é uma
forma de evitar a punição.
Muitos de nós obedecemos a
lei de velocidade
precisamente por essa razão.
Nós a obedecemos mais quando há
luzes de sirene por perto.
Mas também podemos ter uma
versão interiorizada
da redução da punição.
Parte da imagem freudiana que
ouvimos falar na aula
sobre a alma dividida discutia o
desenvolvimento da consciência
como uma interiorização
de regras externas,
em que o superego fica chateado
quando o id se comporta
de um jeito em desacordo com as
restrições da moralidade.
E é possível ter uma
versão não-freudiana
disso quando se apela para a
noção de consciência.
Assim, a ideia de o que a
moralidade traz para você
é tanto a possibilidade de
salvação quanto melhor reputação,
tanto a possibilidade de não ser
punido por leis externas
quanto a possibilidade de não ser punido
por sua própria consciência,
é uma outra versão da teoria
do interesse próprio.
É um tipo de justificação
que alguém pode prever ao se
comportar de maneiras morais.
Um 2º tipo diferente de justificação
diz que o motivo para agir moralmente
é porque as características normativas
são características
fundamentais do mundo.
Existe um grande "deve" lá fora.
É um fato sobre a realidade que o que
estamos moralmente obrigados
a fazer é agir de acordo com as
exigências da moralidade
e não por interesse próprio,
mas simplesmente porque nós
somos responsivos
a essa característica do mundo,
estamos motivados a agir moralmente.
Um 3º tipo de justificação, o 3º tipo
de explicação da motivação,
é o que podemos chamar de
uma teoria factível
que diz, basicamente, que as
pessoas são assim.
Portanto, os modelos evolutivos dizem
que os comportamentos
pró-sociais foram os
escolhidos,
talvez porque possibilitam a resolução
de problemas de coordenação.
Mas seja qual for a explicação,
o comportamento pró-social diz que
foi essa teoria a escolhida.
É um fato bruto do mundo que nos
comportamos de forma pró-social...
não um fato normativo bruto do
mundo, e sim um fato
descritivo bruto do mundo que nos
comportamos desse jeito.
Ou você pode ter, não uma versão
evolutiva com base nisso,
mas uma versão que diz:
esta é a maneira que a alma
humana se manifesta
quando ela está em conformidade
com o seu estado natural.
Então, você pode ter uma
teoria da moralidade que diz
que a razão para se comportar
moralmente é o interesse próprio.
Você pode ter uma teoria da
moralidade que diz
que a razão para se comportar
moralmente é o altruísmo.
Você pode ter uma teoria da
moralidade que diz que a razão
para se comportar moralmente é a
maneira que nos comportamos.
Ou você pode ter algum tipo
de teoria combinada.
E nós já falamos sobre a 1ª: a
teoria do interesse próprio.
E como esta seção do curso continua,
vamos comentar mais sobre outros
tipos de explicações.
Esses são alguns exemplos
dos tipos de respostas
que são dadas à 1ª questão,
a da motivação moral.
Que tipos de problemas surgem
quando refletimos sobre o
comportamento moral?
Bom, vocês viram um monte
de exemplos disso
na leitura que fizemos para hoje.
Um tipo de questionamento que as
teorias morais estabelecem
para buscar respostas é se
é moralmente exigido
ou moralmente permitido
prejudicar 1 pessoa a fim de
ajudar a várias.
Ou seja, a história de Bernard
Williams – "Jim e os índios" –,
coloca Jim numa situação
em que se ele atira em 1
dos 20 prisioneiros,
os outros 19 são libertados,
mas se ele recusa em atirar em 1,
todos os 20 serão mortos.
Ou a história de Omelas, a
história de uma sociedade
cuja prosperidade depende do
sofrimento de 1 criança.
Ou os dilemas do Trolley,
apresentados por mim na 1ª aula,
onde um trem está em
direção a 5 pessoas
e nós temos a possibilidade de
desviá-lo do seu caminho,
o que levaria à morte de 1 pessoa.
Esses são exemplos de
representações esquemáticas
dos tipos de questões
que a teoria moral
confronta o tempo todo.
Sempre que pensamos
sobre diferimentos de ameaça
– é certo colocar em
quarentena uma população
que sofre de uma doença,
causando danos a ela,
mas beneficiando o resto
da sociedade? –
estamos diante desses
tipos de questões.
Um tipo de questão que a
filosofia moral visa responder
é se esta espécie de troca
é moralmente exigida ou
moralmente permitida.
Uma versão particularmente
profunda da questão
surge quando pensamos sobre quais são
os nossos deveres morais perante
os menos afortunados.
O filósofo Peter Singer tem um
argumento de que toda a estrutura
do 1º Mundo e do 3º Mundo é
moralmente ilegítima, pois
envolve uma falta de vontade por parte
dos que estão no 1º Mundo
para fazer o que é
moralmente exigido deles,
isto é, pegar uma grande proporção
dos recursos e redistribuí-los
para as pessoas que sofrem de
doenças bastante fáceis de curar.
As pessoas que não têm
telas mosquiteiras,
as pessoas que não têm vacinas,
as pessoas que não têm água potável,
as pessoas que não têm acesso a
cuidados médicos básicos
nos primeiros 5 anos... tudo
isso, por exemplo,
evitaria a chance de
cegueira ao longo da vida.
Portanto, outra questão que
a teoria moral pede
– algumas vezes na versão da
pergunta anterior – é,
em geral, o que são os nossos deveres
perante os menos afortunados.
Ela também faz perguntas como:
Estes tipos de comportamentos são
moralmente compulsórios?
É moralmente compulsório para
nós o comportamento
que ajuda o meio ambiente – a
reciclagem, digamos?
É moralmente compulsório para nós
agirmos de determinadas maneiras
em relação aos animais não-humanos,
talvez virando vegetarianos?
É moralmente obrigatório para
nós adorarmos uma divindade
de alguma forma? O culto religioso é
algo moralmente compulsório?
O respeito pelos mais
velhos, parte fundamental
das estruturas morais tradicionais, é
algo moralmente compulsório?
E as teorias morais também
fazem perguntas como:
Esses tipos de coisas são
moralmente admissíveis?
O aborto é moralmente admissível?
A eutanásia é moralmente admissível?
A pena capital é
moralmente admissível?
E o sexo antes do casamento?
E mentir em função de uma
ou outra motivação?
Que tal, como Kant discute
na próxima leitura,
deixar de cultivar o talento de alguém.
Kant acha que se trata de uma
violação do mandato moral?
Então, esses são os tipos de perguntas
que as teorias morais buscam respostas.
E isso pode parecer um
bocado heterogêneo.
Mas dá um senso da
totalidade de explicações
que as teorias morais tentam oferecer.
Então, vamos nos focar nas 4 grandes
teorias morais na tradição
ocidental e pensar como elas poderiam
fornecer respostas categóricas
a essa grande variedade de questões.
O tipo de teoria moral que vamos
discutir na aula de hoje é,
essencialmente, uma teoria moral
conhecida como utilitarismo.
Ela afirma que um ato é moral
na medida em que produz o maior
bem para o maior número.
Ela toma como noção
fundamental a noção do bem.
E isso nos dá respostas
para as perguntas
feitas anteriormente,
contanto que a gente saiba
como os bens são
distribuídos em resposta a
elas.
Portanto, se sabemos o que produz a
felicidade nos seres sencientes,
então o utilitarismo nos
dará uma resposta
para se ser vegetariano é
moralmente compulsório.
Ele vai nos dizer para pegar a
quantidade de felicidade
que é distribuída entre
os seres sencientes
e observar qual distribuição
maximiza a quantidade de felicidade.
O utilitarismo nos dá
uma espécie de resposta
sistemática para a questão.
Um 2º tipo de resposta,
que vamos discutir na aula da terça,
é a resposta dada por Kant e a
tradição deontológica.
O que Kant afirma é que um ato é moral
na medida em que ele é executado
como resultado de agir
com o tipo correto de motivação.
Ele toma como noção primária não
a noção de benevolência,
mas a noção de retidão.
E, com base nisso, Kant fornece
um monte de respostas
às nossas perguntas específicas.
Em especial, ele argumenta
que não está OK
sacrificar o bem de 1
pelo bem de muitos.
E ele argumenta que mentir é
moralmente inaceitável.
Na próxima aula, comentaremos
como a partir de um princípio
muito abstrato como esse
é possível derivar essas
respostas específicas.
Já conferimos a resposta tradicional
antiga para isso em Aristóteles,
que um ato é moral na medida
em que ele é executado
como o resultado de ter um
caráter virtuoso.
Portanto, o que
Aristóteles diz é para
ver
como o ser virtuoso se comportaria.
E ao ver o que um virtuoso
faz, você pode aprender
pelo exemplo dele o que a
moralidade exige de nós.
E uma tradição final sobre a qual
não temos muito a dizer
nesta aula é, naturalmente, uma base
para a moralidade que atingiu
o centro da cultura ocidental há
pelo menos 2.000 anos:
a ideia de que um ato é moral na medida
em que está em conformidade com o
que a divindade exige de nós.
Pode-se dar uma explicação,
como faz o utilitarismo,
que apela para a noção
da benevolência.
Pode-se dar uma justificação,
como faz a deontologia,
que apela para a noção da retidão.
Pode-se dar uma justificação,
como faz a ética da virtude,
que apela para a noção da virtuosismo.
Ou pode-se dar um modelo, como
faz a ética religiosa,
que apela para a noção da
exigência divina.
Então vamos refletir um pouco mais
sobre a relação entre essas 3
teorias particulares,
as que vamos nos focar no
contexto desta classe,
tentando compreender a teoria particular
que abordamos hoje, ou
seja, o utilitarismo.
Portanto, a ética da virtude
centra a sua atenção no ator,
não a pessoa que está no palco
e recita Hamlet,
mas o ator que executa um ato
que será moral ou não.
A deontologia centra a sua
atenção no ato.
Ela não analisa quem o realiza,
mas sim qual ato é executado e
sob qual descrição.
O consequencialismo, pelo
contrário, não analisa
quem executa o ato nem a descrição
em que o ato é executado,
e sim as consequências
que o ato acarreta.
E encontramos a teoria da
virtude na voz de...
vejam se vocês reconhecem este
senhor... Aristóteles.
Encontraremos a deontologia na
voz de Immanuel Kant.
E o que vamos discutir hoje –
o consequencialismo e,
em particular, o utilitarismo –
na voz de John Stuart Mill.
Portanto, vamos ver o que
Mill tem a dizer
sobre a natureza
fundamental da moralidade.
Mill afirma...
e é melhor eu avisar que estamos
perto do slide do clicker,
por isso, se você está
um pouco disperso,
é hora de pegar o seu clicker.
Daqui a 4 ou 5 minutos nós vamos
realizar algumas enquetes.
Então, Mill afirma que o
panorama correto para pensar
sobre as teorias morais é o
consequencialista,
não aquele que olha para o ator
como faz a teoria da virtude,
não aquele que olha para o ato
como faz a deontologia,
mas sim aquele que olha para
as consequências
como faz o consequencialismo.
O grau de retidão moral de um ato
é determinado pelas suas
consequências.
E Mill fornece uma versão
particular disso.
Ele diz que o grau de retidão
moral de um ato é determinado
por um tipo particular de consequência,
ou seja, a utilidade que o ato produz.
Você pode ter uma teoria
consequencialista que diz
que o grau de retidão moral de um ato
é determinado pelas suas
consequências, digamos,
a quantidade de bananas que ele produz.
Seria uma teoria moral estranha,
mas seria uma teoria
consequencialista que diz que o
grau de
retidão moral de um ato é
determinado pelas suas consequências,
em especial, pelo seu grau de
produção de bananas.
Isso seria um tipo muito geral de
teoria consequencialista.
As teorias utilitaristas são um tipo
particular de teoria consequencialista
que afirmam que o grau de
retidão moral de um ato
é determinado pelas suas
consequências,
em particular
pela quantidade de utilidade
produzida por ele
– serventia, bem-estar no modelo de
Mill, o qual estamos interessados.
Isso significa que, lembrando das
apostilas que vocês receberam
na seção desta semana, ser
utilitário é uma condição
suficiente
para ser consequencialista, mas não
uma condição necessária.
E ser um consequencialista
é uma condição necessária para ser um
utilitário, mas não suficiente.
E se o que eu disse não é
completamente óbvio para vocês,
deem uma olhada na apostila
que vocês receberam.
Portanto, Mill não só traça um
compromisso utilitário,
no rumo para cumprir esse compromisso,
ele faz 2 afirmações muito
particulares que eu quero pedir
que vocês pensem à luz de
alguns casos particulares.
A 1ª é a famosa formulação do
princípio da maior felicidade,
que no texto de vocês aparece logo
no início da página 77.
Mill diz: "As ações são corretas
na medida em que tendem a
promover felicidade
e erradas se tendem a
promover infelicidade".
E ele continua algumas páginas
depois para esclarecer que não
se trata da felicidade do próprio agente,
mas a de todos os interessados.
E em 1 minuto nós vamos pensar
no que isso implica.
O 2º compromisso de Mill que eu
quero que vocês reflitam
é um que vai contra
o que falamos em Aristóteles
na semana passada.
Mill afirma que o motivo
não tem nada a ver
com a moralidade da ação.
"Aquele que salva um
semelhante de se afogar faz o
que está moralmente certo seja
o seu motivo o dever,
seja a esperança de ser
pago pelo incômodo.
" A motivação com que um ato é
realizado, defende Mill,
não nos diz nada sobre a
moralidade do ato.
Ele não nega que isso nos
diz algo sobre o ator.
Ele é perfeitamente ditoso em
afirmar que quem atua
com a esperança de ser pago é,
de alguma forma, diferente da pessoa
que atua com um senso de dever
ou obrigação moral.
Mas uma vez que o valor moral do
próprio ato está em causa,
Mill acha que não há diferença.
Portanto, este é o 1º
questionamento que eu quero fazer.
Vamos pegar o caso descrito por Mill.
Você vê alguém se afogando num lago.
E a questão é:
o seu ato de salvar essa pessoa
é moralmente correto,
moralmente virtuoso ou moral só se
for feito por obrigação?
Eu quero salvar esta pessoa porque
é a coisa certa a fazer
ou por algum outro tipo de
motivação pró-social...
Se você acha isso, aperte 1.
Ou o ato é moralmente correto
independentemente do seu motivo,
mesmo se você fizer isso porque há
uma placa que diz: "Salvar
uma pessoa se afogando:
Recompensa de US$ 10.000".
E você pensa: "US$ 10.000
é muito dinheiro!"
E você pula na água.
Tudo bem, eu vou pressionar o
temporizador de 10 segundos.
Temos umas 50, 70 pessoas aqui.
Muito bem, os números estão subindo.
Vamos ver se esta sala
está cheia de kantianos ou de
consequencialistas.
Curiosamente, há um
equilíbrio nas respostas.
A maioria de vocês parece
estar com Mill...
que um ato é moralmente correto
independentemente do motivo.
Mas uma parcela considerável
ficará satisfeita
quando lermos Kant, que oferece a
resposta escolhida por vocês.
E uma das tarefas que faremos na
seção da próxima semana
será que vocês, que optaram por um
ou outro lado da questão,
conversem com outras pessoas
e digam por que é que decidiram
por este grupo ou por este.
Até agora Mill está se
saindo muito bem.
Ele tem uma pequena maioria
da sala do lado dele.
Agora eu quero apresentar uma
série de casos e perguntar
o que vocês pensam sobre o
princípio da maior felicidade.
Lembrem-se, Mill diz que um ato é moral
na medida em que produz a maior
felicidade para o maior número,
onde não estamos interessados
com a forma que a felicidade é
distribuída entre os indivíduos.
Portanto, vamos começar
com o seguinte caso.
Existe um ato possível de realizar
em que você ganhará 100
unidades de felicidade.
Cada um destes rostos sorridentes...
vocês não se sentem
pró-sociais vendo eles?
Cada um desses rostos
sorridentes representa
10 unidades de felicidade.
Então, vamos supor que você
tenha um ventilador.
É um dia muito quente
e você tem um ventilador.
E o refresco desse ventilador
proporciona a você 100
unidades de felicidade.
Ou vamos supor que você tenha
alguns biscoitos deliciosos
e comê-los proporciona a você
100 unidades de felicidade.
Além disso, realizar esse ato
dá a 100 outras pessoas
1 unidade de felicidade para cada 1.
Vamos supor que o seu ventilador
sopre um pouco fora da sua sala,
de modo que, além de proporcionar
a você as 100 unidades,
ele refresque as pessoas à
volta com 1 unidade cada.
Ou vamos supor que quando você
termine de comer os 100 biscoitos,
sobrem outros 100, e cada 1 das 100
pessoas come 1 biscoito,
proporcionando a elas 1
unidade de felicidade.
OK. Então, esse é o 1º ato.
Existe um total de 200
unidades de felicidade.
Você fica com 100 unidades e cada
1 das outras 100 pessoas
recebe 1 unidade.
Portanto, a sua escolha é entre
realizar esse ato e realizar
um ato que eu chamo de 2º ato,
que tem exatamente os mesmos
efeitos para você, certo?
Você recebe 100 unidades de felicidade.
Então, aqui está você com
as suas 100 unidades.
Mas, neste caso, se você mudar um
pouco o ângulo do ventilador,
por exemplo, você estaria tão
fresco quanto no 1º caso.
Mas isso dobraria a quantidade de
felicidade nas pessoas à volta,certo?
Você ajusta um pouco o
ângulo do ventilador.
E em vez de 1 unidade de refrigeração,
as pessoas recebem 2 unidades.
Ou, em vez de jogar os biscoitos no lixo
para que as pessoas só obtenham
1 unidade de felicidade,
você deixa os outros biscoitos por aí
e todo mundo recebe 2
unidades de felicidade.
Neste caso, realizando um ato que
não tem consequências
diferentes para você, tanto quanto a
felicidade está em causa,
você duplicou a felicidade de 100
pessoas envolvidas no ato.
Portanto, a questão é
simplesmente esta.
Dada a escolha entre o 1º ato,
que traz um total de 200
unidades de felicidade,
100 unidades para você
e 1 unidade para cada 1 das
outras 100 pessoas;
ou o 2º ato, que traz a mesma
quantidade de felicidade para você,
mas 200 unidades de
felicidade para os outros
e, portanto, um total de 300...
pressione 1 se você acha que
só o 1º ato é moral.
Esse é aquele em que você
tem 100 unidades
e todo mundo recebe 1.
Pressione 2 se você acha que
só o 2º ato é moral,
aquele em que você ajusta o ventilador,
ou seja lá o que você fizer,
isso dobra a felicidade
das pessoas à volta; ou 3º,
que qualquer um deles é um ato moral.
OK. E eu vou voltar o nosso contador
para termos 10 segundos e vermos como é
que vai a sua 1ª experiência
com o princípio da maior
felicidade de Mill.
And let's see how the numbers come out.
OK. Então, muito poucos de vocês
pensam como um ato moral
aquele em que você obtém 100
unidades de felicidade
e os outros 100 obtêm 1 unidade.
Mas vocês estão divididos mais ou
menos iguais nas exigências
da moralidade em que você
redistribui os recursos
de tal modo que eles também
vão para os outros.
Portanto, a maior parte da nossa
discussão dos slides seguintes
se interessa em quando estes 44% se
deslocarão para outro lugar...
Mas eu estou interessada em ver
como tudo isso se desenrola.
OK. Então, esse foi o nosso 1º caso;
o caso em que, sem qualquer
custo para você,
é possível trazer
felicidade para os outros.
Agora, vamos contrastar o 1º caso.
Você fica com 100
unidades de felicidade;
outros 100 recebem 1 unidade de cada 1.
Há um total de 200
unidades, como no 2º caso,
que vamos chamar de 3º ato, onde, a
fim de redirecionar os bens,
você faz a sua própria
felicidade cair para 50 unidades.
Portanto, a fim de
reajustar o ventilador
de tal forma que as outras pessoas
tenham 2 unidades cada 1,
você tem uma ligeira redução na
quantidade de utilidade para você.
Mas isso, em geral, ainda é
benéfico para você.
Então, no 1º ato você obtém
100 unidade de felicidade,
as outras pessoas conseguem 1.
2º ato: você reduziu a sua
felicidade, redirecionou o ventilador,
comeu menos biscoitos, mas você
distribuiu tudo de tal modo
que os outros recebem 2 unidades.
OK. Portanto, a questão é:
1º ato, onde você fica com 100
unidades e todo mundo com 1;
2º ato, onde você obtém 50
unidades e todos obtêm 2,
mas o total é maior; ou nenhum dos 2?
E, mais uma vez, vamos abrir a votação
com o temporizador em 10 segundos.
E vamos ver como saem os números.
Tudo bem.
Um pouco de mudança sobre um
ou outro ato ser moral.
Há mais gente que pensa que
é moralmente exigido
aumentar a felicidade das
pessoas ao redor
quando não há nenhum
dano para si mesmo
que quando existe algum prejuízo.
Observem que Mill é muito claro
que o moralmente exigido
é o número 2 aqui, que somente o ato
que traz a maior quantidade
de utilidade para a comunidade
é o moralmente exigido.
Vamos para o 3º caso.
A 1ª versão é a mesma que antes.
Você fica com 100 unidades.
Todo mundo fica 1.
Agora, a fim de fazer o
bem para os outros
você tem de provar algum
tipo de desconforto.
Você vira o ventilador
totalmente para o outro lado.
Mas o resultado
disso é que os outros 100
recebem 3 unidades cada.
Portanto, a questão agora é esta.
É o ato moralmente permitido, ou é
o ato, que é um ato moral,
aquele que apresentamos inicialmente,
aquele em que você tem
algum desconforto,
mas as outras pessoas
experimentam a utilidade?
Ou eles têm valor igual?
Observem o total de 200
unidades, 250 unidades.
O 1º caso, o nosso caso clássico;
o 2º caso, aquele em que você
sente algum desconforto.
Mas, em troca do desconforto,
as outras pessoas, não você,
experimentam algo de bom.
OK. Vamos acionar o tempo
e ver como isso sai.
OK. Portanto, neste caso,
parece que poucos de vocês
estão ao lado de Mill.
Uns quantos estão aqui,
dizendo que o que precisamos
fazer é oferecer
o maior bem para o maior número.
E uma parcela
considerável está
pensando
que a moralidade talvez não
exija tanto sacrifício.
Seguimos adiante. O próximo caso é
exatamente como o último,
exceto que é outra pessoa com 50
unidades de desconforto,
a fim de distribuir 3 unidades de
utilidade para os outros.
Então aqui está o caso.
Ou você obtém 100
unidades de felicidade
e os outros 1 unidade cada
para um total de 200.
Ou vamos supor que você preserve
as suas 100 unidades de felicidade aqui.
Deixamos esta parte fora da equação.
E a pergunta agora é esta.
Vamos supor que você esteja
distribuindo recursos
para a sociedade como um todo.
Há um caso em que o 1º ato
tem de ser outra pessoa,
de modo que alguém recebe 100
unidades de felicidade
e os outros 100 obtêm 1
unidade cada ou alguém
perde 50 unidades de felicidade,
mas 100 outros ficam com
3 unidades cada.
OK, então vamos substituir você no
1º ato por outra pessoa,
e escolher entre uma distribuição
de recursos na sociedade
que produz 200 unidades de
bem nesse formato
ou uma distribuição de
recursos na sociedade
que produz 250 unidades de
bem neste formato,
menos 50 unidades de sofrimento
de 1 para 300 unidades de
benefícios para os outros.
Qual desses você escolhe para ser
o que exige a moralidade?
E 5, 4, 3, 2, 1...
E vamos ver se há alguma mudança em
relação ao caso anterior.
OK. De repente, temos uma
mudança radical nos gráficos.
Quase 50% de vocês estão certos
de que o ato que requer trazer o
sofrimento para 1 pessoa,
uma redução da utilidade não é
moralmente compulsória.
Mais tarde, na seção da classe
que estamos tendo agora,
vamos considerar se existe um ponto fixo
onde está a linha base e se
essa mudança radical
que temos quando aumentamos e
diminuímos a utilidade
na psicologia das pessoas
sobre o que exige a
moralidade é, de fato,
captada numa diferença artificial.
Vamos passar ao nosso último caso.
Portanto, o nosso último caso
é o de alguém que recebe 100
unidades de felicidade
e os outros 100 obtêm 1 unidade cada.
Então, há 200 unidades de felicidade
ou um caso onde se retira de alguém
5.000 unidades de felicidade,
mas outras 100 pessoas obtêm
500 unidades cada,
de modo que há 45.000
unidades de felicidade
produzidas pelo desenrolar do 6º ato.
O caso aqui é uma posição onde
ninguém é prejudicado,
mas o total de unidades de
felicidade são apenas 200;
ou 1 pessoa é muito prejudicada,
mas o total de unidades de
felicidade são 45.000.
OK. E vamos habilitar a enquete e dispor
de 10, 9, 8, 7, 6 segundos...
e ver como é que vocês
saem nesta questão.
Tudo bem.
Nesta questão, e eu já sei
muitas das respostas de vocês
para o caso Omelas, em que
isso é modelado,
parece claro que o sofrimento de 1
não é algo que a
moralidade exija de nós,
mesmo que o resultado seja o
aumento da utilidade geral.
Agora, como vocês sabem, a
história de Omelas fala sobre
uma sociedade onde há uma
comunidade de pessoas,
cada uma dos quais tem milhares
de unidades de utilidade.
Elas são incrivelmente
felizes da forma que vivem.
Mas essa sociedade existe tal qual só
porque há 1 criança trancada
cujo sofrimento permite a
alegria da sociedade.
E como vocês sabem pela história,
quando as crianças atingem
a idade adulta, elas são levadas para
ver o sofrimento da criança.
E a maioria delas retorna à comunidade
ciente disso, moldada por isso,
mas disposta a tolerar essa situação.
Um pequeno número, ao ver isso,
abandona a sociedade.
A questão que eu quero postular
agora, com base nas respostas
dadas sobre o que é
exigido pela moralidade,
é sobre algumas coisas que parecem ter
a mesma estrutura da
história de Omelas.
Vamos supor que em algum momento
nos últimos 18 anos,
alguém escondeu de vocês que o prazer
ao comer carne depende, assim
como a alegria de Omelas,
do sofrimento de um grande número
de animais não-humanos.
Imagino que vocês notaram na
semana passada e na anterior,
quando a neve caía no
campus e havia trilhas
para vocês chegarem às aulas, que
a possibilidade de você
andar pelo campus dependia de um
grande número de pessoas,
cujas vidas já são difíceis,
levantarem cedo pela manhã
e abrirem caminho no frio da neve.
Espero que alguém tenha
escondido de vocês
que as roupas que vocês vestem
e da qual vocês desfilam uma
certa quantidade de prazer,
são, em grande número de casos,
produzidas a partir de algo muito
próximo com a história de Omelas,
ou seja, o trabalho infantil.
Na verdade, eu assumo que a maioria
de vocês estão cientes
de que a estrutura do mundo
moderno apresenta
uma semelhança bastante chocante
com a história de Omelas.
A possibilidade de
prosperidade no 1º Mundo
é, em muitos aspectos,
uma consequência
de uma estrutura desigual em
relação ao 3º Mundo.
Agora, quase todos vocês
deram uma resposta
que dizia que esse tipo de estrutura
é, no mínimo, esquematicamente
moralmente aceitável.
E a questão é o que está
acontecendo aí...
Na história, Le Guin
sugeriu que vocês,
como estudantes universitários,
estão exatamente na idade em
que a relevância disto
pode afetá-los mais profundamente.
Ela escreve que, depois de terem sido
expostos a estes tipos de fatos,
"os jovens muitas vezes voltam para
casa chorando, ou tão furiosos
que não podem chorar, após verem
a criança cujo sofrimento
depende o destino da sociedade e
enfrentarem esse terrível paradoxo.
Eles talvez meditem sobre isso
por semanas ou anos.
Mas com o tempo começam a compreender
que ainda que a criança fosse
libertada ela não seria brindada
com muitas coisas: o prazer vago
do calor e da comida,
sem dúvida, mas não muito mais".
Agora, uma das coisas
interessantes sobre a literatura
em contraste com a filosofia
é que ela deixa para você
interpretar o que está acontecendo.
E a questão fundamental da
história de Omelas,
penso eu, está nesta frase:
"Mas com o tempo começam a compreender
que ainda que a criança fosse
libertada ela não seria brindada
com muitas coisas: o prazer vago
do calor e da comida,
sem dúvida, mas não muito mais".
É verdade... ou talvez seja o
tipo de racionalização
que o reconhecimento do próprio
conforto traz com ele.
Ela continua, talvez
explicando, talvez protestando,
para dizer o seguinte: "Está
muito degradada e estúpida
para desfrutar da alegria real.
Ela temeu por muito tempo para
estar livre do medo.
Os seus hábitos são demasiado rudes
para responderem a um
tratamento humano".
Aliás, pensem sobre trazer democracias
a países sem tradição de democracia.
"Depois de tanto tempo, é
provável que fosse infeliz
sem paredes para protegê-la, sem a
escuridão para os seus olhos,
sem excrementos onde se sentar.
As lágrimas derramadas por
esta injustiça atroz
se secam quando começam a entender a
terrível justiça da realidade,
e a aceitam."
Eu não tenho uma resposta
para qual das 2 leituras
propostas é a adequada
para o caso Le Guin.
Ela está argumentando ou
ajudando vocês a reconhecerem
que aquela sensação inicial
de raiva com o fato
de que o seu bem-estar depende
do sofrimento dos outros
é, de fato, uma resposta imatura
para uma estrutura inevitável
da desigualdade no mundo?
Ou ela está sugerindo que ao
pensar dessa forma você
está abandonando a sua única chance
para o comportamento moral,
que é quando você está
profundamente exposto à injustiça
e ela golpeia você na forma
de lágrimas ou fúria
e diz que você está em posição de
trazer a moral para sua vida?
De qualquer modo, ela
sugere que viver a vida
com os olhos abertos para o fato
de que o seu bem-estar
depende do sofrimento dos outros é
moralmente compulsório.
Ela continua: "Essas
lágrimas e essa fúria,
a generosidade posta à prova e a
aceitação da impotência,
são, talvez, a verdadeira fonte do
esplendor de suas vidas.
Eles sabem que eles, como a
criança, não são livres",
que vivem num mundo de
interdependência mútua.
"Eles conhecem a compaixão.
É por causa da consciência de
sofrimento no mundo – ela escreve –
... É por causa da criança que eles
tratam tão bem os seus filhos.
Eles sabem que se a miserável
não estivesse submergido
na escuridão",
se nós não tivéssemos os
recursos que permitem
ao 1º Mundo prosperar como ele faz,
"o outro, o flautista não
faria música alegre".
Todas as coisas que nos beneficiamos,
a grandeza desta
universidade, não estaria
aqui.
"Não faria música alegre enquanto
os jovens e belos jóqueis
se alinham para a corrida ao sol
da primeira manhã de verão."
Portanto, eu quero deixar isso
como uma das muitas coisas
que podemos absorver da história de
Omelas e como uma introdução
para a alegação feita por Mill.
E na próxima aula vamos abordar,
no contexto de Kant, algumas
críticas sistemáticas
para o quadro utilitarista que oferecido
nos escritos de Bernard Williams
e a nossa alternativa,
oferecido nos escritos de Immanuel Kant.
Portanto, vejo vocês na terça.